this is a production of Cornell
University
and I haven't actually heard anyone read
the title of my thesis out loud but I do
regret making it quite that long because
when I printed my actual dissertation
most of that just got cut off so you
know for those of you graduating so
thanks everyone for being here thanks
for providing me with this opportunity
to share my work with the department as
as Paul mentioned I was an undergrad
here not too long ago and then and just
recently moved back from Berkeley and so
for this seminar I'll be discussing the
prolific bacterial plant colonizer
Pseudomonas ringing we'll start by
describing this particular study system
and then I'll share my work adapting
randomly bar-coded TN seek to screen for
traits that Pseudomonas ringing requires
to colonize the leaf surface and the
leaf april blast finally I'll share some
unpublished data expanding this work to
alternate host plants and some of the
other directions that I'm moving with
this technology to better understand
plant bacterial interactions okay so
before jumping into the methodology I
want to take a moment to give some
background to the pathless system that
I'll be focusing on so Pseudomonas ring
is a really common bacterial plant
pathogen and so widely used model
partially owing to the early
availability of genome sequence for
multiple strands and it's capable of
infecting many different plants but a
single strand will typically only infect
one or a few much of the specificity has
been linked to the dozens of effector
proteins secreted by the type 3
secretion system which help mediate the
close relationship that this pathogen
has with living plant cells so here I'm
showing different strands infecting
tomato and bean and I want to mention
that even within a single plant like
being you can have multiple strands
infecting the same host so there's a lot
of diversity within this single
bacterial species
importantly the species has found
globally throughout the water cycle so
in addition to agricultural waters has
been isolated from glacial snowpack
rivers and other water sources that are
far from crops one physiological
property that's thought to contribute to
the spread is ice nucleation this is a
property where an individual or a few
cells produce a surface protein that's
actually capable of ordering water
molecules to promote them freezing at a
slightly warmer temperature then that
water would freeze otherwise and this is
thought to contribute to cloud formation
and other movement of water with
associated cells on a global scale on a
more local scale this property can lead
to increased frost damage on a more
positive note this trait has also been
adapted commercially to use in making
artificial snow and this does not
require the use of living cells I have a
quick example of what ice nucleation
actually looks like in real time if it
works
so some strands are more active than
others it's really dependent on the
quantity of ice nuclei like ice
nucleation active or I n a surface
protein in the past this properties been
used as a reporter for gene expression
but we in our lab at this point we
primarily used it as a demo for science
outreach events gets people's attention
so thinking about the many environments
where Pseudomonas string e can be found
it can colonize different plant habitats
as well as chance be found in chance
water sources these represent various
biotic and abiotic challenges to
survival even a single plant or a single
leaf represents multiple potential
habitats at the scale of an individual
cell I'm so for a typical infection
cycle you have cells land on the leaf
surface often through rains flash or
movement from plant debris cells can
reach relatively high population sizes
on the leaf surface this is the there
epiphytic growth stage some strands are
a lot better at this than others and
eventually they're capable of moving
through typically the stomata to
colonize the actually the leaf april
plastic space so actually within the
leaf itself before reaching and they can
reach at that point relatively high
population sizes and cause visible
disease symptoms so these trans maintain
many different compatibility traits that
are necessary for post colonization at
these different steps and one of our
broad overarching questions is what
genes are needed when we know that
growth on the leaf surface can expose
cells to light moisture and temperature
fluctuations as well as nutrient
limitation among other things and the
april plus presents the additional
challenges due to the specific and often
induced plant defense response so
sunomono spring is a very diverse
species complex a recent publication
from david Guttman's group ole
genome sequence from around 500
different strands so with this relative
wealth of sequence data pseudomonas ring
is a really great system for comparative
genomics and I thought this was a
particularly nice example from a recent
review of reconstructing the evolution
of necessary Ireland's traits using
genomic comparisons and so this is a
proposed evolution from a non pathogenic
common ancestor with a Pseudomonas
fluorescens like ancestor to the gain of
specialized virulence traits and these
are ranging from some ancestral traits
like the production of the ply
saccharide alginate the ability to cause
water soaking in plants which are
included among other traits thought to
allow broad environmental colonization
and survival and then more recently
variation in type 3 effector proteins
photo toxin biosynthesis ice nucleation
and other traits are thought to more
specifically be adapted for plant host
colonization but for my focus moving
from comparisons between strands I want
to focus on a single strand so in this
case be 7 to 8 a which was one of the
first 3 string strands to be sequenced
surprisingly a very large proportion of
the genome has a completely unknown
function and this is a model stream
that's been studied for many years for
other organisms this number can be
significantly higher and Laurie Huberman
touched on this last week for many
fungal species as well often homology to
known genes is not sufficient to assign
protein function and so we need tools to
more quickly screen more genes within
diverse genomes for functionality so how
can researchers identify what genes out
of many are important in a given
condition one strategy is to use gene
expression and gene induction as an
indicator of presumably important genes
due to their active transcription in one
or more conditions
so with this example study in d7 to a
day they identified functional
categories of important genes for growth
on the leaf surface and in the a Pope
last so for example flagellar synthesis
and motility genes were relatively
highly expressed on the leaf surface
compared to genes such as those involved
in compatible solute synthesis which
were generally involved generally highly
expressed in in the april blast but also
relatively highly expressed on the
surface as well typically when you've
identified genes that are potentially of
interest in a method like this you'll
want to test this often what people do
is make knock out mutants and test these
for growth phenotypes one by one I mean
this was really my motivation for
setting up TN sake in the system early
in my PhD I constructed and I screamed
many single gene knockout mutants where
these genes were either highly up or
down regulated in planta but this
mutants often had no growth phenotype
and so this led to my interest in TN
seek to functionally examine gene
contributions to Fitness in a random and
generally unbiased way so TN seek or
transposon insertion site sequencing is
essentially a massive competition a say
you can make inferences about relative
mutant fitness within a heterogeneous
population by comparing population
changes over time typically after
exposure to some sort of stress
condition or selection in some cases
competition assays can actually be more
sensitive to small differences in
Fitness than doing parallel growth
measurements
the overarching the goal here is just to
identify important genes and various
conditions by actually measuring their
contributions to fitness and growth
and I'll just remind you that these are
all relative measurements and so using
this simplified figure where the
vertical lines here are representing
essentially the counts of many
independent transposon insertions
throughout these three non essential
genes and you can infer gene
contributions to Fitness by changes in
the relative abundance over time and so
for genes such as this red one that are
important for growth the final
population will be depleted in
insertions in that gene now you can use
this to calculate a ratio of gene
fitness I mean the values are going to
range from large negative values
indicating that that gene was highly
important under that condition to
positive values which indicate that the
gene was actually detrimental under that
given condition and this is a really
powerful method to estimate gene
contributions to fitness for most or all
non-essential genes the challenge with
this method really comes down to the
difficulty in identifying and
quantifying the transposon insertion
sites and so this is where the recently
developed randomly bar coded or RB TNC
comes in this is just one strategy to
make this process easier all that's
really changed is how these counts are
generated so for each insertion a random
twenty nucleotide barcode is carried
along with the transposon into the
genome and so to actually measure these
insertion counts rather than a
traditional library prep which involves
you know random fragmentation of the
genomic DNA adapter ligation PCR
enrichment sequencing and insert mapping
you simply need a single PCR reaction to
amplify all the bar-coded regions within
Universal primer sites and this is done
for all mutants in the population
simultaneously piece of these PCR
primers also include Illumina sequencing
adapters and indices and so these
samples can be multiplexed
um the 10 sikh has historically been a
really powerful approach to screen for
gene function but it requires laborious
sample preparation and analysis as I
mentioned and it also requires longer
sequencing reads because you're reading
from the transposon insertion into the
surrounding genomic DNA to determine
where that insertion actually is here
for this method TN seek is used just
once to map the barcode insertions to
their location in the genome and once
mapped barcode and amplicon sequencing
or VAR c uses very short reads so the
barcodes are only 22 nucleotides long I
mean you can use 50 based bearer
Illumina sequencing reads and this
requires very low relative sequencing
power which enables high multiplexing I
mean this is dependent on the the
machine you're using and at the same
time this method maintains the benefits
of traditional tan seek and so you have
an antibiotic marker for selection of
your library as well as it can be
relative high levels of internal
replication as seen in the multiple
insertions in a single gene so how is
this method currently primarily being
used well it was initially developed by
the Arkin and the Deutsch power labs at
UC Berkeley for high-throughput
functional genomics and in their words
from this recent paper to study
thousands of genes of unknown function
and as you can see from this figure they
have there are 32 different bacterial
strands across dozens of conditions and
they're using these data to identify
various phenotypes for those genes under
those conditions from some of the
improvements that are currently in
development for this method include the
use of additional antibiotic markers and
variance in donor plasmid structure to
use the method in a broader distribution
of bacteria and it sounds like again
based on Lori's seminar last week
they've also moved to fungi using an
agro bacterium mediated method so that's
actually really exciting um
these massive functional genomic studies
are really incredible and they're
already identifying function for
hypothetical proteins and otherwise
improving annotations of diverse genomes
but in our lab we were interested in
using this technique in more complex
growth conditions so for example growth
in a plant host and the conditions being
tested in that in the previous figure
were primarily various carbon and
nitrogen sources as well as antibiotics
stress and so we're interested in
bacterial traits or genes that
contribute to the general ability to
colonize a host as well as virulence
traits that are required to cause
disease
this slide I showed previously where
essentially the infection cycle is
representing the successful colonization
of multiple habitats in a potential
plant host then we were interested in
the diverse compatibility traits that
were required at these different stages
of infection and so I'll start by
talking about my main project of using
RBT and seek to compare growth on the
leaf surface which is epiphytic growth
to colonization of the ablest prior to
disease symptoms appearing
so generally for these experiments the
first step is to construct and map a
mutant population the second is to
actually test it and generate data in
your conditions of interest and so all
libraries require slightly different
conditions depending on your organism of
interest and the transposon vector
that's being used but in this case a
barcode a transposon
containing plasmid was moved from an
equal ID donor library through pooled
large-scale conjugations into my
organism of interest b72 a the resulting
population was sequenced using the
modified two and seek mapping protocol
and we were able to identify over
280,000 independent insertions within
the genome within this population and so
this works out to a median of 21
insertions per gene from the
construction of this library alone 392
genes about 8% of the genome were
predicted to be essential for growth in
LB and we were then able to start
generating Fitness data for 82% of the
genes the remaining 10% are typically
small genes or those that have too few
insertions or too few reads to be able
to generate Fitness data so on to the
interesting part actually testing the
mutant population generating data in
diverse conditions the methodology I
used here for inoculation was either
spray inoculations onto the leaf surface
or vacuum infiltration into the April
blast and the host being used here was
being
for each experiment I grew large
inoculum cultures these were the sampled
is the time zero samples I use these to
inoculate the plants and then harvested
cells either 2 or 6 days after
inoculation by sonic ating the leaves or
the ground leaf tissue and filtering out
the leaf debris as much as possible the
barcodes from purified DNA were
amplified using PCR in sequence this is
the barsik step sorry all right
but in planta the challenge for these
experiments was really avoiding the
bottleneck effects or the potential for
they I don't like effects so how do we
ensure that the diverse mutants in the
population were represented and this is
a challenge for most in vivo
experimental designs and I can also be a
challenge for many in vitro experiments
and so here I'm showing data from a
sample experiment which was growth and
defined minimal media this particular
work was actually done here at Cornell
but I thought it would be more
interesting to show actual data rather
than some of the rough estimates that we
did at Berkeley so for this experiment I
inoculated the library at different
concentrations ranging from about a
hundred fold coverage and so on average
100 strains cells per strand ranging to
a thousandfold dilution relative to the
library size I'm so on the Left we have
essentially the relative the number of
barcodes recovered at these various
dilution so we have ten fold dilutions
of the library and then how many unique
barcodes came out of this the dotted
line is the live the total library size
so as we move to the right of this
dotted line we're adding cells but we're
not adding diversity to the population
so the total number of barcodes remains
constant moving to the left is
essentially diluting out the number of
cells in this population and we're also
diluting out the total diversity I'm
seeing in the number of bar
so from this experiment like we
calculated Fitness across these
different samples and so I'm showing
here to sample genes genes involved in
the biosynthesis of the finding a
tryptophan these genes should be
essential under these conditions and you
can see to the right of this dotted line
as we're adding more cells into these
samples we're able to calculate Fitness
values for these two genes and other
ones these are just examples but as we
diluted at the population moving to the
left of this dotted line we're no longer
able to calculate accurately calculate
Fitness values we hypothesized that the
range and magnitude of these Fitness
values is due to the different inoculum
concentrations that were actually used
at a constant nutrient concentration
which would potentially change the total
number of generations in the experiment
okay so here's my photo of all the
plants that I was using so these mutant
populations contain in the order of 10
to the fifth unique mutant strands so
how big do these pop how big did the
experiments need to be we had roughly
estimate it's estimated that we would
ideally need at least 10 cells per
strand which works out to about 10 to
the 6 cells being inoculated for a given
experiment it turns out that might
actually be a slight overestimate but we
want it to be safe I mean this came down
to a balance between starting with
enough cells to do the experiment
successfully and also not overwhelming
that the plants with pathogen and the
inoculum concentrations that I was using
for these experiments were 10 to the 6
CF used per mil for a spray inoculation
and 10 to the 5 CF use per mil for a
vacuum infiltration and so that was
obviously the more limiting experiments
for each experimental replicate i pooled
100 pots of plants each pot contained
between 5 and 7 plants each plant had
two primary leaves which works out to
about a thousand leaves per experiment
and so this was a lot it was doable but
it was certainly difficult and we had
estimated these values also from a
successful trial experiment that was
done using a much smaller number of
plants at a higher inoculum density
for these large inoculations we
generated Fitness data for around 4,300
genes in these conditions
so kingsby epiphytic growth and a
plastic growth the overall clustering of
these experiments based on total gene
fitness values looked consistent with
what we had expected for each of these
plant experiments they were repeated
three times with two sequencing
replicates each now for most genes
disruption has no effect on overall
fitness and so here I'm showing the
range of Fitness values for the 3 April
plastic experiments where each gene on
the fitness value for a particular
experiment is shown in grey and the
average Fitness values for each gene are
shown in black now most fitness values
are around zero so and this is a log
scale so zero indicates that the
relative abundance does not change over
time it's a log to scale so a fitness
value of minus 2 indicates that the
mutant is about 25% as fit as the
average strand so from the sample
distribution of gene Fitness values
we're looking for the outliers so those
would be really really large Fitness
effects and as a result we targeted
primarily those highly important genes
those were the noticeable fitness defect
after fewer than 8 generations our BT
and seek is proven to be a really
powerful screening tool especially to
generate lists of genes for further
analysis and so for example I identified
33 genes specific to growth on leaf
surface 67 specific to the April plus +
62 genes that were highly important
under both conditions oh and I'll show a
few heat maps like this
where the red indicates the more
negative Fitness values so those are the
genes that are highly important under
that particular condition and I was
looking for consistency within the
functional categories and so for example
genes
involved in amino acid biosynthesis so
here is an example histidine and
tryptophan biosynthesis tended to be
highly important in both plant
conditions genes involved in the type 3
secretion system machinery were highly
important in the April class while
individual type 3 reflectors were
dispensable polysaccharide
polysaccharides like alginate for
example tended to be highly important in
the April blast alginate has been shown
to help cells tolerate desiccation
stress which supports what some of the
previous work that's shown that the
April class is actually a relatively dry
environment often these polysaccharides
are also important on the leaf surface
but for these experiments the plants
were actually kept at a relatively high
humidity environment and so that was not
the case here phyto toxin synthesis and
transport such as the production of
serum my son was were also highly
important in the April blast and I
thought this was a particularly
interesting example because cytotoxins
have been previously shown to be
necessary for symptom formation but not
actually for bacterial growth and so
these data suggest that photo toxin
production is may be necessary for at
least competitive fitness in the plan
so as you might expect when you take a
lab grown population from a rich medium
such as lb and compared to growth in a
in a complex environment
there were many anabolic genes that were
highlighted in the screen and we can
actually think of these highly important
genes as representing biosensor mutants
so these mutants are incapable of
constructing essential building blocks
which are either provided by the plant
or absent and so using tryptophan as an
example this tryptophan auxotrophs was
completely unable to grow in the plant
which suggests that tryptophan is not
present in this environment but on the
other hand we found that catabolic genes
were generally dispensable suggesting
that there are many substitutable carbon
sources present in the in the plant um
the most notable exception was sucrose
which is highly abundant but even those
mutants had a very moderate phenotype
this model for Pseudomonas ringi
metabolism in the beam April blast shows
a sample of the variety of sugars and
organic acids that can be utilized by
central metabolism but generally we
found that mutant strains lacking the
ability to break down any single
molecule we're just as fit as the
average strand
so from this study I was able to
generate genome-wide Fitness data during
colonization of multiple plant habitat
I've highlighted here are some of these
general compatibility traits for leaf
colonization ranging from sort of these
general broad metabolic capabilities to
the production of alginate other
polysaccharides should type through
secretion system and phyto toxins and
this is a very limited list I was
interested in comparing these Fitness
data to previously published
transcriptome data sets using available
previously published microarray data
from our lab I could compare these
expression and Fitness data sets
directly the expectation was that as
expression increases either absolute or
relative to a minimal medium we would
expect these genes to contribute more to
fitness as seen by the decreasing
Fitness values on the y-axis but
interestingly we saw overall no global
correlation between gene expression and
Fitness values the genes that
contributed strongly to Fitness on the
leaf surface and in the April blast
we're generally not highly expressed or
induced in planta but conversely the
genes with the highest expression
changes at Fitness closer to zero and
there's certainly a few caveats for
these comparisons but I think it's an
important point that's worth making
when extrapolating from transcriptome
data sets so moving beyond the single
passage system can we scale the
experimental system so I was interested
going back to this original question of
broadly what are the strategies for
success in diverse hosts and so I tested
the transposon library and additional
plant species tomato is a non host so
there was insufficient growth to
actually test the library but be seven
to eight a is also capable of infecting
lima bean which is in the same genus and
pepper as well as common VM and so
within these compatible hosts are
different genes required for competitive
fitness and compatibility on these
different plants
so to characterize the bacterial traits
that contribute to colonization of
multiple host plants I essentially
repeated the previously described
experiments in lima bean and in pepper
and so the fitness distributions were
very similar between these three hosts
which indicates similar magnitude of
growth and selection on the right you
can see a PCA plot of the experimental
conditions which was generated using all
Fitness values and the treatments are
clustering here is as you would predict
the question for these experiments was
were are any individual genes host
specific and so we expect most genes
just sort of fall in the middle but the
hypothesis was that host specific genes
would skew to either side so the either
blue or the red over here so if a
particular gene had a very negative
Fitness and one host like being but a
Fitness closer to zero and pepper we
would predict that that gene was
specifically important in being however
we saw that there was essentially no
correlation well no there was
essentially no strongly host specific
genes and there was a high correlation
for genome-wide Fitness between the
parent plant hosts and so maybe this
shouldn't have been that surprising
there are many general plant
colonisation traits that would be needed
for in any of these plans but at the
same time we would not just not detect
using this method multiple genes that
have may be subtle additive
contributions to fitness with that in
mind there were genes that while they
were important and all the plants tested
significantly different in Fitness
between hosts so for example there were
certain amino acids like including
histidine and the branched amino acids
that were more important in pepper and
in green bean than in lemma bin
and so this suggests that these amino
acids are more potentially more
available in lima bean and alginate
biosynthesis also came up again in the
screen where the mutants in were less
fit relative to the average strain and
lima bean and a green bean compared to
those mutants
same mutants in pepper and so to wrap up
some of this work we're looking into the
relic into whether the abundance of
these amino acids in the April bus
differs as these Fitness values would
suggest
so today I've talked about my work using
RBT and seek to screen for genes that
contribute to bacterial fitness during
colonization of the leaf surface and
common being as well as the April quest
of common being lima bean and pepper a
major strength of this method is the
ability to very cheaply generate large
complimentary datasets so for example my
previous implant at work focused on a
single strand of Pseudomonas stringing
here at Cornell with the USDA I'm
working on getting this technique
functional for additional bacterial
plant pathogens including the related
model Pseudomonas ring strain TC 3000 as
well as the network traffic pathogens
Dickey added on Tia and Dickey
piccola this gives us the power to
assess not just the genes required for
maximal fitness in multiple conditions
but also to screen for the common and
unique functional traits in multiple
bacteria across multiple habitats or
plant hosts
this allows us to move beyond
comparative genomics which gives us an
indication of the genomic potential to
directly assessing contributions to
fitness using high-throughput functional
genomics and so to wrap up I'd like to
highlight really how open end of this
work is and I'll mention that while this
is simply one of many complementary
tools that can be used RB T and C really
has tremendous potential so for example
measurements of gene expression compared
to contributions to Fitness are both
really important and I think useful
measurements for my for my analysis I
pull the existing transcriptome data
from the literature but I think it can
also be really useful to actually
generate those those data in parallel
and actually control for some of the
conditions that I was not able to
control for in my analysis tans seek in
non wild-type strands such as deletion
mutants can be a really interesting way
to better understand gene regulation
gene redundancy and metabolic pathways
and so last year we actually published a
story that I didn't talk about today
where I constructed a transposon library
in a mutant background so one that was
lacking a major drug resistance a flux
transporter and I was able to use that
to identify alternative and redundant on
toxin tolerance chants sorry about that
as Paul mentioned with my introduction
the the global Fitness profiles can be
compared to protein and metabolite
measurements and I think this is
currently a very underutilized method
but probably comes down to some of the
difficulties with the current tools
available for actually making those
protein and metabolite measurements and
then finally if this technique or if
this methodology sounds interesting to
you it's actually really easy to use if
the libraries are already constructed
and so one resource aside from talking
to me is I recommend checking out
the fitness browser so this is a website
that was constructed and maintained by
the Arkin and boys fire labs and it's a
little bit confusing to use but if you
click on this organisms button on the
main page it has a list of all of the
strains where libraries have been
constructed and published and so you can
go through it's mostly
proteobacteria at the moment but you can
go through see if there's anything any
strains or latest trends of interest and
for each strain the website also
contains all of the experiments that
have been done with all of the
corresponding Fitness data across the
genome for those experiments so this is
actually a really a really rich resource
all right most of the most of the work
that I described today took place under
the guidance of Steve Linda at UC
Berkeley and I'd particularly like to
highlight the work of the many
undergrads that I had the pleasure of
working with and and also stradun who
was actually an early rotation student
all of the RBT and safe work was done in
close collaboration with Adam Dwyer in
his group they provided the donor e-coli
libraries as well as the the resources
for the sequencing and the analysis
pipelines at Berkeley I'd also like to
thank my my current lab I'm currently
co-advised by Paul and Melanie so thanks
for the opportunity to speak today and
thanks everyone for coming and so with
that I can take questions
[Applause]
yeah so
we actually thought there would be more
did I mean as you might expect that
trait that property is very rare where
if you disrupt a gene suddenly your
mutant is more fit there was the
occasional regulator so one or two two
component systems popped up but those
phenotypes tended to be very mild and
also very limited to what conditions
they appeared in so for as an example I
think one of the the largest increases
in Fitness happened or I don't remember
exactly which one but a two component
system on the leaf surface but those
same mutants were highly unfit in the
way proplast
so definitely a trade-off and II so I
know I shouldn't be worried to waiting
too much worried about a cheaters about
what cheaters oh okay so I've talked
about this before but were you surprised
that if you only have like 10 or 12 out
of 3000 or whatever genes involved in
the type III secretion apparatus that
means that most of your neighbors are
able to make the apparatus and most
cells are at the 50 that you're using
most cells are you know interacting like
a recent rise by that so we were we
thought a lot about that and he the
thinking currently at least the thinking
that makes me feel best about this
experiment is that when we did the
inoculations we did expect them to be in
relatively high density and you would
expect more than one single cell to be
interacting with a plant cell I'll just
do to the scale and so if that were the
case then you should get that
complementation between those mutants
that cannot deliver effectors and those
that can and so we were pleasantly
surprised essentially to see that those
secretion system mutants were coming up
in our screen and what my interpretation
of that is that the inoculum density
actually was low enough that they didn't
get complementation at the beginning of
the experiment which was when most of
the growth was taking place
you know growth curves in the April
Plast you typically get a lot of growth
pretty quick and then it plateaus a
little bit and so my expectation is that
there probably is complementation later
on in the experiments but all of the
growth is happening at the beginning and
that's actually what we're measuring and
so that's without actually looking to
see you know that's sort of where our
thinking was
you should I don't know how to do that I
just asked me to my girlfriend Chanel
amuse himself are there any questions
from Geneva
okay what are we looking for no we just
asked them and they so I I think it's
kind of interesting that the fitness for
the individual teams and the to call
them modules is somewhat varied imagine
that could be statistics but I noticed
for instance that algae is loss of algae
is very detrimental for fitness and we
know that Alan to you is also a major
regulator of other systems mm-hmm so you
see these individual genes that
contribute more Fitness than others and
I'm wondering so there's cheaters
there's other other functions for some
of these genes potentially do you see
any patterns is there any way of setting
these things out like looking at
regulators specifically these genes that
are contributing to Fitness regulators
necessarily oh they're other they're
other secondary function says some of
these things might be playing somehow -
data to figure that out I guess the
realize I have not been repeating the
question which I should have been but in
this case to see if I actually
understand the question
you're asking if these genes have other
roles in addition to their like
enzymatic functions or like how you
would screen maybe for additional
function in asking you about these
particular pathways I'm just noticing
that for instance out.you which we know
and so is
are there have you run into other
instances or are there patterns and we
keep looking for in the data it might
give us hypotheses for further
experiments to test you know these
things might be important in other ways
yeah so I'm not sure if from these data
you can get a sense of if like if these
genes would be functional in other ways
I mean one of the one of the big caveats
for the analysis is that especially in
plant
the fitness eyes can be very can be
highly variable due to the nature of the
experiments and so we talked a lot about
well Steve and I talked a lot about
trying to pull out genes that have more
moderate phenotypes because in this case
most of the analysis I did was pulling
genes that had these really screaming
huge fitness defects because that's
essentially the low-hanging fruit for
these analyses if anything that's one of
the challenges with these experiments is
that the analysis that I've done is
basically scratching the surface there's
a lot of other stuff that can be done
working working within the DSU that
these results can be really variable
in terms of regulators at least I think
that is where you can get some really
interesting stuff looking at looking at
what happens downstream when you start
disrupting these pathways although I
don't that can be that can be a lot yeah
we can talk about that more because I
think maybe I'm not totally
understanding no I think you do
understand sure there are some ideas
from mining data so for your Spring
inoculation data do you find chemotaxis
genes like to be like strong outliers
like having very negative impact on the
statements oh that's a really good
question
I think motility was an interesting
example for the leaf surface because
what I was seeing did not fully line up
with what people have seen in the past
yeah I think the reason for that might
have been so for what I saw was
primarily the question regarding
chemotaxis and motility on the leaf
surface
I saw generally flagellar mutants tended
to be more fit you know those those
genes those proteins use up a lot of
energy and the assumption that we were
making based on the Fitness values I was
looking at was that the inoculum density
was high enough that cells didn't need
to move around that much um if they
landed in spots on the leaf surface that
had nutrients they grew and if not they
were probably immediately out competed
by other cells that did and so from
these experiments I didn't really see
any chemotaxis genes popping up as being
important but I think that might have
been more of an experimental artifact
than anything related to the importance
of those genes on the leaf surface which
have been shown previously to be really
important one more question
so the inoculations were community
inoculation
correct you're done yet strange so the
inoculations were of a pooled mutant
population inoculated simultaneously so
then and this is going back to tears
also but it's so in order to verify that
youth that these actually Fitness
defects are not necessarily due to
competitive interactions but actually
due to some type of inhibition and the
pathogen ability to in effect in order
to separate those two you we need to run
these experiment using the bacterial
mutants solo right yeah so this this
method is a really good screening tool
to generate a lot of data at the same
time but you're right in order to to get
a better sense of the the phenotypes of
any single mutant it is really valuable
to make a targeted deletion test it by
itself so that you don't get these
community effects and I certainly did
that for some of the mutants I was
looking at again mostly those that had
really large fitness defects but that
essentially became the limiting step is
picking out genes to actually doubt it
so it's worth noting that software
that's used to do the analysis and
statistics on these results we have it
working at this point in our labs so if
this is something that you guys are if
anyone who's interested in looking at
this please talk to Tyler all right this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu